[Applaudissements]
mamelle Cléo mamelle Cléo au premier
jour je me rappelle c'était chez des
amis idiots mademoiselle Clio
mademoiselle Clio votre maman avait des
ailes dans une robe de tafta vous étiez
une demoiselle et je vous murmurai tout
bas dormir avec vous
faire un rêve à deux quand le ciel est
noir au fond de ma
chambre le sommeil est doux quand tombe
la pluie quand le vent du nord murmure
tout bas
descembre tous les mots d'amour le vent
nous les dit quand la cloche sonne une
heure perdue
lointaine oublier la vie oublierz nos
peines dormir une nuit dormir mon amour
dormir avec vous mademoiselle Clio
mademoiselle Clio vous êtes marié c'est
ridicule avec le fils de ces idiots
Mamoiselle Clio Mamoiselle Clio votre
mari est somnambule il se promène sur
les toits toute la nuit tandis que moi
je D avec vous dans le même lit nous
rêvons tous deux quand le ciel est noir
au fond de ma
chambre notre corps charmant soutne la
minuit dans un petit hôtel tout près de
la rue de
l'ambre il y a pas d'eau courante et
pour faire P c'est au fond de la cour
mais là-bas il y a pas de
lumière
[Musique]
maises sont
familières j'attends notre
nu votre
mari dans une crise F de ball dans la
peau
M
[Musique]
m je suis bien
Morton en
dis permis de revenir toutes les
nuits dormir avec vous sans vous faire
peur caressz vos cheveux toucher votre
cœur vous dire à
l'oreille je t'aime chérie je t'aime et
j'en meurs et tier les poils du petit
cocu qui
veille la commode qui grin un bruit sur
le toit le lit qui chimie c'est dans le
bois
Bru je suis courant d' et rayon de lune
j'ai
l'éternité pour chanter tout bas je dor
avec
[Musique]
toi